how fast the universe is growing has
been a question astronomers have been
trying to answer since the late 1920s by
the 1990s data from the Hubble Space
Telescope estimated the speed of the
expansion of the universe a number
called the Hubble constant to somewhere
in the 70 kilometers per second per
megaparsec range in 2011 the best data
put it close to seventy four kilometers
per second per megaparsec it seemed as
if the Astronomy community was finally
settling on a number then in 2013 data
from the Planck satellite suggested a
lower number for the Hubble constant
planks measurements indicated that the
universe was expanding at a rate of
sixty seven point three kilometers per
second per megaparsec that doesn't seem
like a big difference but it is planck's
value is the best fit for a whole model
of the universe including one for the
nature of dark energy so the discrepancy
could mean that astronomers recipe for
what makes up the universe is a little
bit off the universe could have a little
more dark matter an ordinary matter and
a little less dark energy than
previously predicted despite what the
plank data suggests astronomers aren't
quite ready to overhaul their
understanding of the universe scientists
say they need more data which they'll
get from satellites such as Gaia maybe
then they'll have a better idea about
what makes up the universe and what its
ultimate fate will be